well the afghan government has suffered
further setbacks in trying to hold off
the seemingly relentless advance of the
taliban the humanitarian crisis is
deepening there as tens of thousands are
forced to flee the fighting the
militants are estimated to control
two-thirds of afghanistan
shaky and shocking video purports to
show taliban fighters celebrating
victory after taking a town in farah
province in the west
they appear to be dragging the body of a
killed opponent in images too disturbing
to show they then throw the corpse into
a pit and begin shooting at it
and it's scenes like that which have
prompted many afghans to leave their
rural homes and seek sanctuary in cities
like these people in a makeshift camp at
a park in kabul
tens of thousands of families have been
displaced and there's not enough food or
other relief material for them
the displaced people are in a terrible
and frustrating situation but the
government has not sent a representative
here to help
as the afghan government struggles to
contain the taliban's military advances
it's also appealing to the world
community for humanitarian support
customers
we call on the international community
and international institutions to help
as soon as possible to provide food and
non-food items to the many people
displaced in afghanistan
many have questioned the very speedy
withdrawal of the u.s led international
forces which is due to be completed this
month but criticism is also being
directed at neighbouring pakistan
for not using its influence over the
taliban to end the bloodshed and rights
abuses
pakistan's foreign minister mahmoud
qureshi rejected the criticism and said
his country would quote play its role to
facilitate the afghan peace process
we have done whatever we could and we
will continue to do uh what we can
for peace for stability
and for regional connectivity
it is in sync
with the agenda of our government
the return of the taliban and the
possibility of a lengthy civil war are
likely to prompt an exodus of refugees
many heading west towards europe
greece was often the first point of
arrival in the eu during the 2016
migration crisis
athens says it's not able to handle
another such wave of arrivals
well joining us for more is asha kurum
she's a law student at kabul university
and a former afghan youth representative
to the un asia thanks for joining us
you're talking to us to from the afghan
capital kabul what is the situation like
where you are now
well starting uh from kabul um right now
each and every day there are flights uh
from the airport that take thousands of
passengers from kabul that are fleeing
their homes and seeking refuge and
foreign land
and different countries some of them to
some of the neighboring countries and at
the moment people who are
uh who were living in the provincial
capitals or the places that are right
now under tolerance control
they
they are eve each and every day fleeing
their homes and there is a flood of igps
um sweeping into the capital
city kabul and uh there are right now
thousands of refugees
that are also leaving um kabul but the
people who are coming to kabul they
perceive that the safest of place for
them is um kabul that isn't far to face
the same fate as as other provincial
capitals by the end of august when u.s
troops fully withdraw from the country
so
the people who are relying on on kabul
as the safest of places um might be
facing the same disaster they faced in
their own homes if we can just go back
to something you said there have been
reports sourced to u.s intelligence that
the taliban could take kabul within 90
days if they continue at their current
pace how many people as you mentioned
are preparing to leave the city already
a lot of people
every day there are flights that are
taking thousands of passengers out of
the country and some of the people they
do not have the luxury of even leaving
the country um and they cannot afford it
financially so the people coming to
kabul they rely on the government they
rely on the international community that
focus their um their help to the capital
city couple all these years um so right
now idps they do not um
even have the support that um
international community provided for the
kabul itself in the last 20 years there
is no humanitarian response provided for
the idps
that are without shelter without food
and they are losing even their kids
because of the
lack of food and and the
and problems they are facing in kabul
aisha
are you at risk as the taliban closes in
well everybody is at risk but
specifically in the past few years we
when there was a chain of targeted
assassinations um when there was attack
on my university on my faculty people
like me were supposed to be killed and
assassinated in order to pave the ground
for
the oppressive regime of taliban to
revive once again in afghanistan for the
voices like us to shut down and not to
speak again um but we cannot afford to
leave the people
who
are relying on our support at this
moment so
yes our lives are at risk but we are
committed to fight as long as we can
while acknowledging that risk with how
much hope are you looking to the united
nations for a peaceful resolution to the
conflict in afghanistan
well at this moment um when it comes to
first of all to the united states and
nato forces there is a strong sense of
disgust and disappointment nobody is
relying on their help anymore but united
nations it has a big rule an important
role to play it was created for this
moment to save humanity from sinking
into a chaos that would be irreversible
so um one while ago when there was an
origin meeting uh convened by the united
nations security council hopes were
very high and people expected an urgent
response to be made by the international
community but soon it was revealed that
national interest
and and the politics supersede humanity
and 75 years after united nations
creation we're still witnessing the same
mistakes we made
when when the united nation was not
created yet so
unless the united nations take
a decisive action in order to save
afghanistan from collapsing into chaos
we will be witnessing a very dangerous
humanitarian crisis once again
aisha kurdham thank you so much for your
insight